all right we're gonna start this week's
uh covet update a little differently
than we usually do we'll start globally
and then
work into the us instead of starting
with the united states because right now
the the global context is increasingly
important to figure out what's going on
because globally cases are actually
almost at a peak right now we're we are
almost
at a pandemic high globally with about
675 000 cases per day which is close to
the
absolute highest point we had uh was
about 745
000 cases per day so thanks to just huge
spikes in some countries and then
small spikes in others we are of
all of this time going all the way back
to whenever we're calling the beginning
february of 2020 or really even earlier
although we didn't know the number of
cases at that time we are essentially
close to the global peak of cases right
now
now it's important to understand that as
more people
get vaccinated cases will mean less and
less
in the sense that a covid case will
less and less likely be something that
results in a hospitalization or results
in a death as more and more people are
vaccinated but the important thing to
understand is that globally we are
nowhere near that point in time right
now of the world's roughly 8 billion
people
only 788 million doses
have been administered and since some of
those
you know or two shot regimens under one
percent
of the global population has been
vaccinated right now
so for now a global case spike
does mean more deaths eventually the
cases right now
are highest in india turkey
here in the united states in brazil
in france and poland those are the top
six right now
so with that is the global context
what's happening here in the united
states well let's now
take a look cases in the united states
sort of level
slight uptick bottomed out around 55 000
a day
now back up to about 65 000 cases per
day
so we are simply in a fight right now
it's variants
and young people going crazy against
vaccines
and we'll talk by the way in the next
segment about what's going on with the
johnson and johnson vaccine which which
is going to be paused at this point in
time we'll get to that
uh but you have places like michigan and
in the northeast of the united states
with the more contagious british variant
increasingly dominant
more and more young people getting the
virus uh and
you you've got that up against more and
more vaccinations that fortunately are
being done
the good news is that this entire time
deaths have continued to decline when
what was it six weeks ago
we saw the case decline level out we
said
we might see death's level out in three
weeks as well that hasn't happened
uh deaths peaked in mid to late january
around 3 500 people
uh dying per day just inconceivable
tragedy
now down to a still tragic but about 80
percent lower
750 deaths per day that
should continue to decline as
vaccination is rolling out
we have not yet vaccinated enough people
to see cases
collapse we are vaccinating enough older
and at-risk folks that increasingly
people getting the virus are less and
less likely to die and that's exactly
why you start
with the oldest and the most vulnerable
some states
and and this is good news and then we'll
get to what's going on with jnj
in a moment some states are only about
a month out from herd immunity
massachusetts is a state for example
where 92 percent of the population wants
the vaccine
more than one percent of the population
is being vaccinated daily
approaching high 30s percent vaccinated
and could be at 70 percent
within 30 to 40 days now for comparison
when
israel got to 50 vaccinated
cases just fell off a cliff went down
very very quickly so that could be
coming in some states
in other states like mississippi
vaccination is happening really slowly
uh not nearly as much interest in the
vaccine
many unscheduled you know appointments
in mississippi that are just remaining
unscheduled and available
so it remains to be seen what happens
there now as far as vaccination
we saw another single day record
of 4.6 million doses on saturday
nearly another 3.6 million doses
on sunday these are really incredible
numbers so the playbook
is keep vaccinating anyone
at risk that you can convince as to
the importance of getting vaccinated
that's great
and then don't go crazy just yet we know
that the pfizer vaccine is less
effective against the south african
variant
the vaccines work well against the
british variant basically just as well
but it is more contagious so that's
that's quite literally a race
the path out is vaccination likely
boosters in the fall
or winter modified for the variants
that's where we are
so we have to keep going at this point
most people i know personally have had
at least one shot even younger
people full eligibility happening
nationwide on april 19th
that's in six days that's all great the
problem now
is what's going on with the johnson and
johnson vaccine so we should talk about
that next
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number
the privacy app and the browser plug-in
let you give each company
a randomized virtual credit card number
that you create out of thin air it'll
even autofill the card number with one
click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private by
not telling companies
who you are you're keeping your bank or
credit card info protected against
data breaches and identity theft and
it's free
and like i said you'll get five dollars
to spend when you sign up at privacy.com
slash pacman